wouldn't it be great if there was a
recession indicator that we could all
look to that was so accurate that it had
predicted every recession without fail
since the 1950s
well there is it's called a yield curve
inversion and the warning lights for
another one are flashing right now i'm
going to tell you what the yield curve
is and what it means when it inverts
why it's been such an accurate predictor
of recessions for the last 70 years and
why we could be seeing another one soon
the us government pays interest to
borrow money and that interest rate
fluctuates constantly on the open market
the longer it takes to be paid back the
higher the interest rate at least that's
how it works during normal times when
the economy is solid so you see what's
known as the yield curve the further out
in time you go the higher rates are
our video team did a full breakdown on
bonds the yield curve and yield curve
inversions in march 2019. if you want to
do a deeper dive in the mechanics check
out the link in the comments as the
economy struggles you start to see the
yield curve take on a different shape
and if things don't get better you see
the curve in verb
a yield curve inversion happens when the
interest rates on long-dated treasuries
are lower than those on short-dated
treasuries when investors see the
economy starting to struggle they start
to demand higher interest payments on
short-term bonds that's because bonds
are less likely to be paid back when
economies are in trouble and the
movement shows that the demand for money
now is greater than in the future a sign
that the economy is slowing down that
tends to be a good signal that a
recession is about to happen
the yield curve has inverted before
every single recession since the 1950s
and the federal reserve has even said an
inversion is a quote reliable predictor
for an economic downturn if you look at
a chart showing the difference between
the 10-year and 2-year government bond
or the 10-year and 3-month bond
it goes negative or inverts before every
recession researchers at the fed say
that's largely because the interest rate
on the 10-year note reflects long-term
perceptions of the economy while
interest rates on the two-year note are
largely a reflection of monetary policy
when monetary policy is pushing
short-term interest rates higher but
investor sentiment is falling you can
see the yield curve invert now that
inversion hasn't happened yet
but the market is headed in that
direction
so far this year we've seen inversions
of the 20-year and 30-year bond the
five-year and 10-year note and the seven
year in tenure the difference between
the interest rate on two-year and
10-year notes recently declined to the
smallest it's been since 2020 when the
u.s had its most recent recession
that difference also known as the spread
has been compressing pretty consistently
for most of 2022 this has been a result
of continued high inflation pushing up
expectations for the fed to raise rates
as well as worsen the economic sentiment
and worries about the conflict in
ukraine
one hopeful caveat for investors and the
rest of us who don't want to see a
contracting u.s economy is that an
inversion doesn't mean an immediate u.s
recession the time between an inversion
and a recession has varied from 6 to 24
months and stocks typically perform well
during that time things could still turn
around and the curve might not invert
we've seen that before and to be sure an
inverted yield curve doesn't cause a
recession it's just a warning sign so an
inversion doesn't mean a recession has
to happen
but i'm always skeptical of the four
most worrisome words in finance
it's different this time
if you enjoyed this video hit that like
button and subscribe to keep up with my
latest videos on markets i'm reminded of
the late great biggie smalls
who said stay far from timid only make
moves when your heart's in it and live
the phrase sky's the limit i'll see you
next time